first of all fantastic film safety not
guaranteed we've got it here at Sundance
London very first Sundance London what's
it mean to you to be part of this
obviously you've been over in Utah and
now they've chosen your firm to come
here yeah you know I I think that this
film for me it represents something
uniquely American and that this is a
character who has extraordinarily high
confidence levels without a lot of
evidence that he can do what he says
he's going to do and well that I guess
you could say that might be a negative
trade I consider it a positive one and
it's something that of the things that
make me proud of America that's that's
one of them is the the tenacity to to
try and pull something off that everyone
else as impossible and that's that's
what the movies about do you think those
are qualities and that you need is a
filmmaker as well for you to seen this
film through from scripts to the film
that we see on the big screen right now
I think it's absolutely one of the
qualities and I think that in the
American indie system which is very
different that we don't have government
assistance in any way for any filmmakers
just the way that people have to just
claw and scratch and beg and borrow to
get films made is different than
anywhere else in the world and it takes
that very independent spirit to get it
done yeah we have a date at all in the
UK for the release of the film yet we
don't were June eighth in the United
States and we're opening Canada and
Australia and if people demand it and
want to see it then hopefully we can
find a way for them to see it I'd love
to be here well good luck with that very
much hope they do thank you